next up right now actually i should say
here at 637 helping families through
grief it is what drives adam's place
that is a local non-profit devoted to
guiding people through very dark times
and this weekend the organization is
holding it's a second annual 5k they're
raising money and awareness for the need
and the cause and we're emceeing so
we're excited to be out there and we've
got bianca holmen now joining us with
the folks from adam's place to talk more
about the work that they do here in the
community and the big event this weekend
bianca
hey good morning john good morning
heather so like you said adam's place
helping families navigate grief and loss
and we know that when kids don't deal
with that grief and loss it can result
in some negative behavior so they're
trying to curb that and make sure that
we have our healthy teens and and
healthy youth that grow up to be strong
adults and be able to cope with that
loss properly so tell us about the 5k
happening this weekend the money raised
goes towards camp cope yeah so exciting
it's our second annual event
we're in person this year so we're
thrilled about that we have something
for everyone there's our kids obstacle
course our 5k our one mile fun walk we
have a pet costume
contest right now room
change she's now a reindeer and we're so
excited to have all the community out
we've got some special guests that'll be
joining us so we want everyone to come
out and see who those folks are all
right and also i hear people the kids
should bring their their christmas list
right yes yes we're taking letters to
santa and uh we've got some here in our
bag already but we'd like to get them to
santa so he has plenty of time to make
some wishes come true exactly navigate
those supply chain issues right well
again uh
camp cope is a great uh activity that
adam's place hosts every single year and
they're actually getting into the
schools and so we're joined here by a
family who's participated in camp cove
we have kelly here and her mom linda so
tell us mom why wasn't so important to
have your daughter involved in this
program
just because a lot of kids don't
understand loss and grief and not know
how to process and adam's place was
there to help us and guide us through
all the different coping skills we know
it's hard as adults it's probably even
harder for kids so
kelly how was it for you participating
in the camp and being with other kids
who have had loss in their family like
yours it was definitely a better
experience knowing that you aren't alone
and that there's other kids out there
who are going through the same thing you
can get help and there's always help
available yeah and giving them the right
tools to navigate it you know it's
nothing that life really prepares you
for no one can ever tell you this is
what you're going to feel and just
talking with the folks here it's a
journey we know that loss and grief is a
journey and it's never over so again
adam's place great organization they've
got camp cope that they're raising money
for 5k is happening this saturday we've
got all the details on our website and
again come out if you can this saturday
to help participate in the 5k happening
here at jaguar land rover las vegas send
it back to you guys in the studio
incredible such a well-spoken young
young woman yeah well-spoken and a great
cause and bianca a great interview as
well thank you very much and enjoy the
sloth behind you yeah say hi to the
sloth say hi to the sloth for us we've
liked this all morning we were talking
about it